>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Hello, everyone.
Thank you for joining us today.
My name is Betsy Peterson
and I'm the Director
of the American Folklife Center
here at the Library of Congress.
And, on behalf of all the
staff and the library,
I want to welcome you.
We're very excited
about today's event
and very excited to
have you with us.
And, before we move
along, I just wanted
to tell you a little bit about
the American Folklife Center
for those of you who don't know
that much about what we do.
We are a center here
in the library,
in fact in this very building.
We were founded in 1976 by
Congress with the mandate
to preserve and present the rich
diversity of American Folklife
and we have strived hard for the
last 41 years to do just that.
Now, Congress selected the
library itself as the site
for the center in part because
the library already had a pretty
significant archive of
traditional music and culture,
which had in fact been
established in 1928.
So, it was already pretty darn
big by the time we started
and it has only grown in
magnitude in the last 40 years.
We now have over six
million items of recordings
of traditional culture,
traditional music,
stories from over a hundred 140
countries throughout the world
and I certainly I want
to invite you to come
and listen to some of it.
But, the other reason that I
think they selected the Library
of Congress is because it
is, it's America's library
and it has a strong commitment
to preserving the rich diversity
of voices in the United States
and indeed throughout the world.
And, I think this even today is
very much about that commitment.
So, one of the ways in which we
continue to grow our archives
in - in the last few decades is
certainly through partnerships
and partnerships with other
organizations, other individuals
and I think today's event is
very much about that as well.
And, I do want to thank our
partners for this event today.
The Muslim American
Leadership Alliance.
Thank you very much.
And, thank you very
much to Zainab Khan.
I don't know where Zainab
- ah, you're right there.
Right in front of me.
And, Naeem Uddin
[assumed spelling].
I do - I don't know
if Naeem is here.
Oh, welcome.
I - I gather you came all
the way from New Orleans, so.
Welcome. And, I also would
like to acknowledge Mohammed
Aziz [assumed spelling],
who I hope is here.
I believe he is one
of the board members.
Ah, okay. Welcome and thank you.
I also want to acknowledge
StoryCorps [assumed spelling]
who is one of the other
very critical partners in -
in this event today and in this
project that Zainab is going
to tell us a little
bit more about.
So, once again thank you to
our staff, thank you Zainab,
thank you MALA, and
thank you StoryCorps
and welcome once again.
[ Applause ]
>> Good afternoon, everybody
and thank you so much
for taking the time out and
joining us this afternoon
for what I hope is a very, very
compelling program that each
of you can understand
how much heart and soul
and effort was put into it.
For the past two and
a half years, MALA,
Muslim American Leadership
Alliance, has really,
really worked hard to collect
archive and preserve the stories
of diverse Muslim Americans.
And, what I really noticed was
that as a Muslim
American myself,
I felt that my voice
didn't belong.
I didn't know where
my story would belong
and where my voice
would be accepted.
And, hence, a group of us had
started the Muslim American
Leadership Alliance
and we're very proud
to showcase the narratives
on the collection
of stories that we have today.
MALA is a 501C3 Civic and
Community Organization
and we're committed to promote
individual freedom diversity
and to celebrate heritage.
Our core storytelling program is
to amplify voices
of Muslim Americans.
Really when you think about it,
Muslim Americans are the most
broadest and diverse group
in America, holding the
broadest range of diversity
across ethnicities,
nationalities,
various demographics
in this country.
These stories are a prime
example of liberating new voices
from behind a cloud of
stereotypes, the stereotypes
that have come from
within the community,
stereotypes that have
come from the media
and actually providing
people a platform
to share their personal
individual experiences.
To date, MALA has collected,
archived and preserved
over 350 stories of
Muslim Americans and many
of these stories were also
archived into the Library
of Congress and really through
our community partnership
with StoryCorps, several were
even aired on NPR programs.
And, as you listen
to these stories,
you'll hear just a small
sample of what we've been able
to produce that presents just
the vast diverse experiences
that really make us human.
These are stories of people that
hail from Kazakhstan, Albania,
Algeria, Siberia even, India,
Iraq, Iran, Israel, Somalia,
Mauritania, Mali,
Nigeria, Morocco, France -
pretty much every country
- Palestine, Yemen,
Saudi Arabia, Venezuela.
All of these people
hailed from these countries
yet have shared their
story as Muslim Americans.
And, I really hope that
these stories will continue
to have an incredible
potential to harness engagement
and build bridges all while
stressing the importance
of inclusion and individuality.
I want to thank the
American Folklife Center
for providing us the
opportunity to hold
such a significant event.
I want to thank StoryCorps
for over two and a half years
of partnership as
we continue to grow
and record stories all
throughout America.
And, I want to thank the
Library of Congress also
for providing us this incredible
opportunity for generations
to come to come back and listen
to these stories and have pride
in the personal experiences,
whether they are triumphs,
adversities, struggles,
they are human journeys
and they ought to be recognized.
We will now play a
sample compilation of some
of the stories that have
been produced and even aired
in partnership with
StoryCorps and NPR.
[ Music ]
>> I was born in Algeria.
My parents were elementary
school teachers from Syria
who during the post-independence
period
in Algeria taught
Arabic and Algeria.
So, I was born there and
then we went back to Syria
and I was raised in
Syria, went to school there
and to medical school
in Damascus University,
graduated from Damascus
University Medical School
in 1988 and came right
after that to Chicago.
I was first in class in
medical school and I remember
that I gave the graduation
speech
on behalf of the big class.
We had about 550
people who graduated.
And, among the graduates at that
time was someone whose name was
Bashar al-Assad, who was the
son of the President of Syria
at that time, Hafez al-Assad.
Hafez al-Assad ruled Syria
for 30 years and at that time,
Bashar was not being groomed
to be the next president.
His older brother was, Bassel.
Every Syrian dreams of the day
that they will go back and try
to rebuild what has
been destroyed.
Every Syrian American dreams of
the time that they can go back
and walk peacefully in the
streets that they got to know
and eat in the restaurants
that provide Syrian cuisine
and listen to the
music of Syria.
It looks like it's going to
be a long way from - from now.
[ Music ]
>> We begin with me
as a 4-year-old child
who came from Pakistan.
My father wanted a
better life for us.
He wanted us to go to
school and I came to America
and I remember being
called Hindu
and being called all these names
because kids just didn't
understand my culture
and I would be like
embarrassed if my mother
who wore the head scarf
would take me to school.
As a child, you don't
know, because all you want
to do is fit in and I
remember I was in fourth grade
and I had a crush
on this Greek boy.
His name was Leo something.
It's a long last name.
And, I remember thinking to
myself why even look at him,
Nyla [assumed spelling]
when you know you're going
to marry someone else.
Imagine what that's like for
someone in the fourth grade.
So, in October of 2004,
I went to Pakistan.
They said oh it's
your cousin's wedding.
You know that was the trick to
get me there, that we were going
for my cousin's wedding and
the next thing you know,
January 5th came along
and that's the day my
whole life changed.
[ Music ]
>> I think as a Muslim
American, as an Arab American
who has grown up in the
United States his whole life,
I was born and raised
here from parents
who immigrated from Syria.
Now, I think one of the main
reasons why I wanted to come
down here and speak about
my story is because I am one
of the very few Arabs or
Muslim Americans who decided
to branch off from being a
doctor or engineer or lawyer
and do something
completely out of the norm.
And so, right now I
am a videographer.
I've been doing video,
telling stories
for about nine to ten years now.
I'm not in it for the money
and I'm not in it for the fame.
I'm in it for the next
generation that is to come.
The next generation out
there who are like my brother
or my sister or even my kids,
I want them to grow up knowing
that they can be
something that they want,
that they can put their mind to.
You can be a firefighter.
You can be a - someone that
wants to be on the news,
someone that wants to do
something in PR, communications.
Anything that you can put your
mind to, you should go for it.
[ Music ]
>> My dad is [inaudible]
and my mom is half
Russian and half Iranian.
It's interesting because my
grandmother is actually Jewish
and my grandfather is Muslim
and he's actually Shia Muslim.
And so, then my dad and his
parents are Sunni Muslim.
So, in addition to the different
cultural like practices,
there's also differences
in like religious sect.
What I've realized is I've grown
up as that kind of one culture
and just religious sect kind
of like was more
prominent in my life.
So, definitely the
Palestinian culture
and practices I've learned way
more about than Iranian culture
or even Russian culture.
That's probably what
I've learned the least
about is Russian Culture.
And, then I am [inaudible]
Muslim too.
So, yeah, I've just
realized that.
I didn't really have the
opportunity to learn as much
as I would have liked to
about Iranian culture,
Russian cultures, as
well as like Judaism
and [inaudible] Islam too.
[ Music ]
>> I hope you enjoyed that
little montage of a snippet
of just a compilation
of the rich stories
that we've been able to
collect and preserve.
Now, I am very excited
to announce three
of our panelists today who
have also shared their story
with MALA.
And, I want to thank
them because they came
from three different states.
So, from New York,
we have Zabi Rahat.
So, please come on up.
[ Applause ]
We also have Supna Zaidi
from Washington, DC.
[ Applause ]
And, finally, we have Ahmed
Salim from Chicago, Illinois.
[ Applause ]
So, three different stories,
three different journeys.
Zabi starting from
you, you know,
could you share a little bit
about just your journey here
and also what compelled you
to share your story with MALA.
>> Hi everyone.
Thanks for coming.
Before I start, I did
my story with MALA
and I was very thrilled with
what MALA is doing and all
of these stories and diversity
of American - Muslims in America
and - and also the
communities they live in.
I came to U.S. - I was born in
Kabul - in Kabul, Afghanistan.
I spent my early
teen years in Kabul.
I was living there during
the entire Taliban period
and then I moved to U.S.
when I was in eleventh grade
through a State Department
funded exchange student program.
And, the way the exchange
student program worked was
that the students would
be placed randomly
across the U.S. anywhere.
And, I was placed
in Berne, Indiana
and I don't think you can
even find Berne on a map.
I came from Kabul.
Kabul has a five
million population.
Berne had five thousand
- the entire town.
My high school in Kabul
had ten thousand students.
Berne had five hundred.
I don't think they had
ever seen a brown person,
let alone a person
from Afghanistan.
So, it was an unbelievably
amazing experience living
with this family that took me
in and became my legal guardians
after that exchange
student year ended.
And, Berne, Indiana is not like
Washington, DC or New York City.
It is a very conservative,
majority white,
I would say Republican town.
So, combine all those, you
already have certain perception
of what that community
would look like.
But, to me it was my family
there and the were [inaudible]
and the way I became such
a really important part
of that community really changed
my perception of what America -
what small town America
is all about.
So, one of the reasons I wanted
to share my story was because of
that family and friends I
found in - in a part of America
where you always hear about
racism, you always hear
about bigotry, but to me,
I made friends with one
of my friend's grandpar
- grandad who I went
to their house and
played cornhole with.
I don't know if you
know what cornhole is -
if you're from midwest
- Mideast U.S.,
you will know what cornhole is.
And, I drank moonshine
with them.
[Laughter].
And, I wasn't - I was under
age, so just forget about that.
But, he was a Vietnam veteran.
So, when I told him I was
from Afghanistan and he was
like so welcoming and - and
then we sat, we - we, you know,
we had - they had
a whole barbeque,
but that's what made me want
to share my story is that a kid
like 16, 15, when
I was in undergrad,
then I spent time in Ohio.
Very young kid from Afghanistan
in the middle of nowhere
in America making friends
with the most unlikely people.
And, they welcomed me.
All of them.
I mean, of course, there's
certain racism that you feel,
but for the most part, it was
an amazing experience and one
of the reasons I wanted
to, you know, share.
>> I think that's an incredible
story, Zabi, and, you know,
I think what you - what you
also mentioned is very important
because dispelling stereotypes,
I think your story
in itself does that.
It goes against the grievance
narrative and it actually shows
that you were welcomed, you were
able to create a new identity
and an American identity and you
were welcomed and you obviously
as a human you experienced
things,
but it's - it's a success.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
And, it - I think maybe
a little different
because I was a student.
So, I was in university,
living on campus in a dorm room
and all freshman kids, this
was a new experience for them.
So, everybody coming to
live in a campus dorm room,
they're all away from home.
I was away from home, so all of
those kids were away from home.
And, we all had that one shared
experience of being students
in a small, you know, campus.
That's - I would say that was
an opportunity and an advantage
for me to be able to make all
these friends and, you know,
with different communities.
>> That's great.
Yeah. Supna, you had also shared
a very compelling story with -
with MALA as a, you know, Muslim
American with your heritage
and your, you know, very unique
story of where you come from
and your parent's story.
So, if you could share that
with us that would be wonderful.
>> Hi everyone.
Thanks for coming today.
So, the profile I wrote focused
on I guess two stages
of my life.
Me through my parents and their
experiences having left Pakistan
in 1981 and the context in which
they left and then me growing
up through the 80s and 90s
and getting married about,
you know, four years ago.
And, for me - I'll get
into the details of those,
but the one common thread
that I realized in writing
that which was most compelling,
especially in the context of,
you know, for millennials,
especially growing up post 911
and being any minority,
not even just Muslim,
is that there's always
adversity,
there's always experiences
that we go
through regardless whether
there's economic adversity
or something having to do with
the disability or any kind
of disadvantage that we
experience that makes us
in the moment feel like we're
going through something worse
than others, but in
hindsight when you look back,
it's a learning experience.
You grow from it.
You're a better person
through it.
And, the politics of today
make things feel more sensitive
and worse or makes us feel
that we're in a situation
that can't be overcome, but
when you look at the experiences
of everyone around you
that, you know, precede more
than one generation, like
my parents coming to America
or anyone in this audience
whether it was their
grandparents or great,
great grandparents that came
to the U.S. from somewhere else.
We've all been through -
we as in our family histories
have been through periods
where we had to figure out who
we were, what our identity means
to us and how we
can integrate it
to all being American
at the same time.
And, I think that's something
that for me means everything now
in our political environment
when I look at my nephews
and nieces who aren't even 10
yet of what I'm going to share
with them about what it means to
grow up American and be Muslim
or Pakistani or anything
other hyphen that you want to,
you know, put in
there for yourself.
And, with my parents,
they left Pakistan in 1981
as the country was being
[inaudible] during the cold war
under the dictatorship of
Prime Minister [inaudible].
My dad was a liberal who was
part of Pakistan Television.
His dream was just to be like
a filmmaker, write soap operas,
[inaudible], dramas
and just, you know,
his friends were
writers and musicians
and he was a very jovial person.
And, with increasing religious
[inaudible] that was coming
into the public's fear
of Pakistani society
[inaudible] became a factor
of your employment.
And, because my dad didn't fit
into the expectations of the -
the government and a certain
increasingly orthodox society
was expecting of him, he
basically got demoted.
I was born in a city called
Karachi, which was - is -
continues to be pretty
cosmopolitan like New York City.
My dad was general manager
of Pakistan Television.
He got demoted [inaudible],
no offense,
but [inaudible] was not
exactly where he wanted to end
up if you were in the
television industry.
And, because my family didn't
come from a wealthy background,
we were lucky enough
to be able to immigrate
to the United States where
my father had a sister
who had already settled here.
My parents started over.
My mother was a painter and with
my father's background in film,
there was really no
translatable, successful career
to start over again
in the United States.
They had a little apartment
and my parents first
jobs were fast food.
And, especially I think for
a person like my father,
that has to hurt personally in
terms of who you think you are,
what you've achieved in life
and where you're
starting over at 40.
I'm 40 now myself.
My father has passed away.
It's been ten years and I
can look back at my childhood
and look at all kinds of
different experiences we had
that were difficult, but I think
I always just attributed it
to being an immigrant.
That first generation,
understanding
that people aren't going
to get certain things
and yeah it sucks.
You know, sometimes you
don't have enough money
to do the things your
girl friends are doing
in sixth grade.
You're not going to get
to go to the slumber party
because your parents don't
understand the culture
and they're afraid of all kinds
of bad things happening to you
because they have a lot of
time to make up a lot of stuff
and watch the 4:00 news and
they think that's all American
society is.
But, you know, we fight, we push
for boundaries, we - we learn
and ask for more
responsibilities to figure
out our own space and we
figure out what all the labels
that are being put on
us actually mean to us.
For myself, my family
is [inaudible],
which is a minority
- religious minority
in Pakistan - Muslim
minority even.
So, growing up in
Southern California,
I couldn't even just say I was
Muslim, because among Muslims,
I was a different thing.
So, I never really
fit in anywhere
and it took me a long
time to be okay with that.
And - and, all the friends
I made by the time I was
in college happened
to be - to be blunt,
middle class white
girls who grew
up in conservative
families like me.
What we had in common were
the simple joys of life.
We were going to the
movies at 10:00 at night
and our parents weren't
there to get mad at us.
It really had nothing to do
with a specific religion.
And, our values were the same.
We were studying, we were
trying to go to law school
or med school or whatever and
our friendships were based
on our trusts that we had
in each - in each other,
the respect we had for each
other and just being girls.
But, the exposure we also had
to each other's families
allows us to learn.
My best friends were Catholic
or Jewish or Hindu or Vietnamese
and Buddhist and
they came to my house
and it was a Muslim household
and they were exposed
to Pakistani food, south Asian
clothing, Bollywood music
on the radio if my
dad was playing it
and it was [inaudible]
of experiences.
It wasn't just being Muslin,
because Muslin doesn't -
it has no one singular
definition.
And, if you fast forward
today when I look at my nephew
and niece who are 9 and 7,
they're growing up in Indiana.
They're, I think, the
only Pakistani kids
in their neighborhood.
My husband's Catholic
from Richmond
and their favorite visit to
Virginia is for Christmas.
And, I love the fact
that they have exposure
to different faiths and
not different cultures,
because they're 100%
even more American
than me, they were born here.
And, for them, they
don't flinch.
They easily move fluidly from
wearing Pakistani clothes
on Saturday because they're
going to some baby's baptism,
which we call [inaudible],
or then, you know,
going to a Christmas
party the following week
because it's December 20
something and it's the season.
And, to me it's that fluidity
that makes America great.
It's that respect and
balance that the public
and the community irrespective
of politics and irrespective
of whatever particular
moment we're in.
That as sense is being American
is not going to go away in mind
and it lets me be Pakistani,
American and any other thing
that I listed in my profile
and that why I couldn't
ever live anywhere else.
>> Thank you, Supna.
That was very, very well said.
Thank you.
Ahmed, you have also had
a very compelling journey
in achieving the American
dream and I'd love for you
to share a little bit about
your own personal experience,
what you shared with MALA.
>> I'm terrible with
technology and it continues.
First of all, thank you.
So, like everyone else,
I am an immigrant.
I from Pakistan.
Actually, immigrated here when
I was 2 and my parents came,
you know, same message,
American dream.
And, you know, I thought
it was important to talk
about the American dream.
I don't think people really -
they don't really give gratitude
to the idea of the
American dream.
You know, I'm now 33 and, you
know, my entire life I grew
up saying, you know, I immigrate
and not really understanding
what my parents gave up and,
you know, what they had to
go through and what we went
through really to assimilate.
So, I came here at
2 and my parents,
you know, changed careers.
My dad was in the
Army back in Pakistan.
My mom was a housewife.
My dad opened up shop.
He was hit hard with
the recession
like a lot of other people.
He lost his house or our
house, he lost his business.
I actually got into law school
at the same time that happened.
Not once did they flinch.
Not once did they complain
about being in this country.
They figured a way
to get me my loans.
They figured a way to make sure
I was able to attend law school.
I worked. My - I liked to
- I like to brag, you know.
You always hear parents say I
had to walk 20 miles in snow to,
you know, get to school.
My third year of law school, I
went to school out in Michigan.
I - I lived in Chicago.
I scheduled all my classes for
Thursday afternoon and Friday,
so I used to drive
up Thursday morning,
sleep on my friend's
couch Thursday night
and drive back Friday
night to avoid paying rent
and I would just buy him dinner
and I worked a sunglasses kiosk
on the weekends and
during the week.
So, about 40 hours a week.
So, I can't wait to
tell my kids that story,
because I legitimately
am going to hold
that over them [laughter].
But, that's the idea, right?
That's the American dream.
My parents, you know, I saw
that work ethic growing up
and I was able to replicate it.
You know, and that
actually lead me
to my basically currently
professional life.
I, you know, I do compliance
law for a health system
in Chicago and, you know, it
lead me to my current decision,
which, you know, I won't
go into detail here,
but I decided to run for office.
And, you know, running
for office right now is -
is basically like the pinnacle
of an immigrant's dream,
like seeing your child being
able to run for office.
And, you know, truth be
told, after I decided to run
for office, my dad, 67, was
let go from his job because he,
you know, wasn't technical
savvy enough to keep
up with the computer
systems at work.
He didn't complain.
What did he do?
He literally the next day
signed up to be a Lyft driver
and drives Lyft as a
67-year-old [laugher].
And, that's what I mean when you
talk about the American dream
and really making sure that, you
know, we appreciate it and it -
it - it - we take it for granite
for the idea that we hear it
so often but, you know,
there are people who believe
in the American dream so much
that stuff like that happens
and they just keep
rolling with it.
And, you know, they see their
kids and I'll see my kids based
on the fruits of my parent's
labors and, you know,
it's something I really
think is important to share.
>> Thank you Ahmed.
That's - that's a very - that's
a - that's actually something
that I think resonates
quite frankly with a lot
of us sitting in this room.
Especially coming as
a, you know, from a -
a child as an immigrant, the
sacrifices that people have made
to make sure that your
life here is what it is.
You know, I know myself, my
own father escaped oppression
and subjugation in its
worst form from Afghanistan
and came here and
rebuilt his entire life
and his identity here and
I know what he sacrificed
and what he had gone
through to ensure that myself
and my sisters have the
life that we have now.
I'm going to open the floor
to the audience for Q&A.
you know, please take
advantage of the panelist
that we have here and also any
questions that you may have
in regards to the
storytelling process.
You're more than welcomed
to go on our website,
which is www.malanational.org.
You can share your story.
You can read the stories.
You can listen to the stories.
And, you know, the
floor is open.
And, Thea [assumed spelling] is
walking around with a microphone
in case anybody has a question.
None? Somebody has
to have one question.
>> Hello. I am also from
Pakistan, so I can pretty relate
with the two persons
here, Supna and Ahmed.
And, as my projecting, I
believe from results based
on assimilation of Pakistani
community in the United States.
And, I have one question
from Supna.
As you just mentioned that you
married to a Catholic and how -
how the Pakistani community and
the families perceive such kind
of marriages in which, you
know, there is a huge difference
of religion and the
nationality and ethnicity
and there is a difference.
So, do you think
that all families
across the board accepts
that and if they don't,
which communities do
not accept it as such?
>> Thanks for your question.
Well, interfaith marriages
are a new experience
for first generation immigrants.
I mean, every Pakistani
family isn't first generation,
but predominantly they are.
And, I think the insularity
that maybe is where you're going
like with your question is
sometimes coming from a place
from parents where they
have fears of the unknown
and being immigrants that
have migrated from one place
to another, it's not
that they're anti whatever
the other is, but it's more
of fear of preserving.
Whether it's language
or culture.
I remember when I was young
my father would say oh
if you marry out, you know,
how will I talk to him.
I'm like, you speak
English perfectly fine.
But, his point was his command
of, you know, his argument,
his - his emotion, his heart.
That would be in [inaudible].
That wouldn't be in English.
And, so I - he - he's coming
from an emotional place
when he said that, you know,
and I can understand that
and I think that's probably
why it took me a long time
to get married, because I
spent a lot of years trying
to meet somebody that
- and this is the thing
about identity right.
Someone can fit on
paper on the outside,
but that doesn't mean they
fit you on the inside.
Because I - I like everyone else
here, our experiences are unique
to us and they're
like in our heads.
They're not external.
And, you know the funniest
thing I can you tell you
about my husband is
that on the outside,
we couldn't be more different.
Voted opposite at the
election, different religions,
all kinds of different stuff
but, you know, no one reminds me
of my family more than
him, like his habits.
Like the way he says and
does little things reminds me
of my dad sometimes.
His love of family.
When he - one of the most
enduring things he ever did
for me was when we were dating,
because my mother had
already been widowed,
he didn't even tell me.
He sent her a Valentine.
My brothers are not going
to do anything like that
for anybody ever, you know,
and my husband does that.
So, personal relationships
should be respected as such
and I think interfaith
marriages are happening more
and more slowly as - as
families become more integrated
in the United States.
I think my age group had
the hardest, but when I look
at people in their 20s,
I'm amazed they're
dating in college.
We were not allowed
to date in college.
I mean, you wouldn't do that.
People are meeting their
spouses on their own.
Arranged marriages are
more becoming from my ex -
from what I've seen more in
name rather than practice.
You know, I call it
the mommy network.
You know, parents are
introducing their kids,
but it's not like,
you know, here's Bob,
you're marrying him on Friday.
That's a real arranged marriage.
That's not happening.
And, then, you know, in that
same vain, people are looking
for people who they
get along with
and that is increasingly
crossing labels,
whether it's religion
or nationality
and I think that's just again
part of the immigrant experience
and not necessarily
unique to Muslims.
>> That was a great
question and answer.
We have another one.
>> So, actually wanted to
join this conversation.
My father is from Multan.
He grew up in Delhi, which tells
all the Pakistanis in the room
that my family isn't Muslim.
He was born in 1940 and he
came to the United States
in the early 70s where he met
and married my white
unitarian mother.
They got married
in 1973, I think,
and I think that you're
really right when you say
that it's different
generationally, right.
So, I'm about your age
and I think it's probably very
different for people dating now,
but for my parents, even then
there were certainly people
who made my mother welcome
immediately in the community
and people in my
mother's community
who made my father welcome.
I think the issue a
lot of it had to do
with what were expectations
for children.
And so, the - I think now
people who are raising kids,
there's much more acceptance
on the part of the parents
and the goal is that fluidity,
whereas I think that growing
up the child in one of those -
those blended marriages
in the 1980s.
My sister and I and our
inability to speak Punjabi
for instance was
scary to parents
who were immigrant
parents in a way
that I suspect it's
maybe sad sometimes --
>> Yeah. Losing identity.
>> -- for parents now, but it's
not terrifying in the same way.
And so, I do think it's the sort
of forward moving progression,
maybe towards something good,
maybe just different, right.
>> Right.
>> But, yeah very much
what you're saying
and I think I see something very
different for friends of mine
who marry across than
I saw for my parents,
even though I would
say they found a lot
of acceptance 50 years ago.
>> And, I think it'll
be very empowering
for Muslim communities,
you know, speaking broadly
because when you
look at Americans
of Muslim backgrounds
growing up here -
or even traditional
backgrounds -
I should probably
take a step back.
It's not just Muslims.
A lot of issues that come up in
the Muslim context actually have
to do with traditional
[inaudible] cultures,
Middle Eastern cultures, not,
you know, strictly Muslim,
or Indian cultures,
South Asian culture.
There's a lot of stuff
especially having to do
with women's rights issues.
Anyway. With that, the
point what I was trying -
my point is more that like
when people like my age group
or younger grow up in western
cultures like American culture
and we integrate our
heritage with being American,
which also includes
American values
and American sensibilities,
what I'm seeing when you look
across the media is you also -
you see more liberal interp -
understandings of what it
means to be a woman or Muslim
or Pakistani and I think that
goes back into the community.
So, you know, a little girl
being raised going to Mosques,
excuse me, today
is probably going
to hear a lot more enlightened
interpretation of what it means
to be Muslin or Pakistani
or whatever other, you know,
national background she might be
of than maybe what my
mother was exposed to
or even what I was
exposed to coming
to America, you know, 1981.
>> I think for anybody
in this room also
that has a very compelling
story I do encourage you to go
on the site and definitely
share your story,
because it is an open platform.
You can submit your story, your
headshot and it would be amazing
to feature you, especially
your unique narrative as well.
Are there any other questions
from anyplace that I overlooked?
Oh, I'm sorry.
There you go.
>> Hi. I had a question
for the last speaker.
So, I'm kind of wondering what
you - what exactly do you mean
by the American dream?
Because like - I don't
know, like it seems
like the way you're describing
it is kind of like in terms
of like material successes.
How do you think that
that kind of intersects
with the way Muslims in this
country have been criminalized
and marginalized consistently
and perhaps especially
under this administration?
>> Well, I'll - I'll -
I'll start with that.
I think the most important thing
is that, you know, a) it's the -
the stories themselves are
not just about material gain,
but it's about the sacrifices
and the opportunities
that America has had
provided for people that come
from all walks of life, you
know, not just Pakistan, but,
you know, all different
countries
and not just economic
growth, but actual freedom
and opportunities and democracy.
And, you know, there's a lot of
Muslims that come from countries
where there was a lot of
injustices that also existed
where democracy doesn't exist.
I think that's kind of where
Ahmed was touching on that.
Now, in regards to
anything about politics
or the current administration,
that's not something
that we comment on.
Quite frankly, our organization
and our whole project is
to exemplify what Muslim
American experiences are
and how Muslims have contributed
to this American
fabric of society.
So, going back into that
Ahmed, you can answer
that question as well.
>> Well, it restricts just
a bit, so we can always talk
after in case you need to.
But, yeah, it's beyond material
benefit and gain in a spec -
in a respect of the
American dream.
I think when I'm referring
to the American dream
in my parent's eyes, it's really
just making sure that, you know,
they're children had the
opportunity specifically
with education and I think every
single person on this panel
and stories we've heard or
stories I've seen on MALA seems
to be the general
message, right.
The American dream is making
sure your kids have a better
life, meaning education,
democracy, freedom,
the ability to basically
practice and do what you want.
And, that's what my parents
gave me and that's what I mean
when I speak about the American
dream in respects to my parents.
>> My parents - I
don't even know
if they understand what
American dreams are,
what the American dream is
supposed to be because they're
in Afghanistan still and they
live there and they work there.
And, my American parents now
they never once mentioned
to me American dream, but
they raised - they have -
I have four other older siblings
and they raised all of them
to be the, you know, the
values they instilled in them
to be a good person, get
education, get a job, you know,
be independent and, you know,
try to make a difference.
And, but, you know,
being here and learning
and I think that's what
American dream for me
than slowly how it translated
to and realistically when I was
in Afghanistan, American dream
was living in New York City.
[ Laughter ]
And, now I do live in
New York City and it's -
some dreams shouldn't come
true, because New York City --
[ Laugther ]
-- it's busy, overwhelming, the
subway's smelly and, but I -
expensive and, but I like it.
But, that dream did come true.
>> Thanks for your questions.
We are going to now wrap
up in the next segment
which is essentially another
montage of our compilation
and then we will also
then go into an introdu -
an introductory to StoryCorps,
the archiving process
and then remarks from the
American Folklife Center.
[ Music ]
>> I was born in Venezuela
and my parents are Lebanese.
They immigrated to Venezuela
when they were very young.
And, so I have that
mix of cultures
and to me it was
natural to be able
to understand the
different cultures.
The American culture,
the Lebanese culture,
the other Arabic cultures
that we have in Venezuela
and then moving to
the United States,
I feel that I gained an - an
additional culture as well.
So, I - I identify with people.
That's how I think it's
made it easier for me.
So, I don't identify
necessarily just
with the culture as a whole.
I see it as bits, pieces,
elements, you know,
within a culture and there
are things that I like,
things that I don't like, you
know, I adopted as my own.
My identity is solely
encompassing.
I always reject it, identifying
with just one culture.
I find Venezuela is
where my heart is.
That's what I was born,
that's what my family
is, that's what I know.
But, I've been living here in
the United States in Michigan
for 20 - almost 21 years, so
I've been here for so long
and I - I do feel
American as well
and Michigan is my home as well.
But, it's easy for
me again to go back
to Venezuela, go
back to Lebanon.
It's still my home as well.
So, I just would
like a time I guess
in which I'm not challenged to
identify or show solidarity,
you know, to specific group.
I don't want to identify
as Lebanese or I don't want
to be identified as only Muslim.
I don't want to be identified
only as a Latin-American.
I want to be identified as a mix
of all of this because I feel
that I understand all of
them, then why I'm going
to be cornered into just
one so people accept me.
I think that people
should accept me
by my different identities.
That's what makes me who
I am and I don't need
to accommodate anyone.
[ Music ]
>> My story begins just
outside Chicago, Illinois.
My mom and dad they are
immigrants from India.
My father comes from a very
small, dusty village outside of,
well about nine or
ten hours outside
of Mumbai called Bilongo
[assumed spelling] and he left
that place when he was
16 and my mother grew
up in Heatherbod [assumed
spelling] - she was born
in Heatherbod, but grew up
in Bombay, very much comes
from Heatherbodi [assumed
spelling] and that's kind
of what's, you know,
interesting about, you know,
people think Indians and
Pakistanis were, you know,
kind of one big thing, but
really it was a subcontinent,
so every state, every culture
has its own flavor and I grew
up with both of those.
The South Indian culture,
as well as the Heatherbodi,
Mormoli [assumed spelling],
North Indian culture
in my household,
which was really cool.
I started out in
college studying opera
because it became very
apparent later on in high school
that I had a voice that
was well suited for opera.
So, I rigorously studied the
art of singing and the art of,
I mean, classical music forms
whether that be the rudiments
of music theory, oral skills,
just the grounding that -
that is good to have if one is
to pursue a career in music.
Growing up around Indo-Pakistani
music, as well as black music.
I mean, my mom and
dad, you know,
really liked listening
to Motown.
They liked listening
to James Brown.
They liked listening to Stevie
Wonder among other things
and my dad had a profound
appreciation for black culture
and the black narrative
here in America.
I mean, I remember
when we were growing
up on Martin Luther
King Day, it wasn't just
like a holiday where, you
know, we - we just ran outside
and played like the other kids.
My dad would - had this
rule that we'd have
to come home for dinner.
There would always be
something on TV about Dr. King
and he made us watch it
and around dinner time,
we would have a discussion
and every year,
my mom and dad would say, you
know, you have to be grateful
to Dr. King and what he did
because if it were not for him,
we would not have been able
to come to this country.
[ Music ]
>> I'm originally
from Somaliland.
It's a breakaway region at
the northwest side of Somalia
and we - we were born and raised
in Abu Dhabi then we came here
and moved to Chicago
permanently in 2002.
So, when I came here,
I was 11 years old.
It was very hard coming
into this country.
Culturally, it was very
different being a Muslim,
especially after the Twin Towers
were attacked in New York.
I was looked at differently.
I wasn't exactly sure whether
I should be a practicing Muslim
or just fit in with other kids,
so it was just very
hard to assimilate.
I just - I was just lost.
There was this situation
where I was in class
and my teacher asked
me where I was from
and I told her I was born
and raised in Abu Dhabi
and then she was like oh so
you were born in a desert and,
you know, the, you know, the
kids were laughing and I -
I just felt like should I
hide where I'm from, like,
everyone's kind of
laughing at me
because everyone actually
Abu Dhabi was a desert,
but it's a country, you know,
and there aren't
habitants of people.
So, I kind of starting
talking like my peers.
I guess I was sort of trying
to be American, but in reality,
I lost my Muslim identity.
[ Music ]
>> I was born in Baghdad,
Iraq and it was a very civilized
nation that I think a lot
of people, you know, don't
know all of it's history,
but it's very well
established and very well off
up until recent events.
We left at the time, I think
I was probably about 4,
and I just remember not really
knowing what was going on
or what was happening,
but that, you know,
there was something
definitely off
or something definitely wrong
because I saw, you know,
how upset my parents were
and I vaguely remember being
at a bus stop with them
and my grandparents
and we were supposed to be
just taking a, you know,
doing air quotes, like
a vacation, you know,
because we weren't
supposed to be leaving Iraq.
And, even with just
having immigrant parents
like the stories that they share
I think really paint a picture
of, you know, just how
difficult they had it over there
and how hard they worked.
I mean, my parents are
probably conservative.
They controlled a lot
of things that I did
and with our cultural
background, you know, it's,
I mean, it's already hard
enough for parents to hear that,
you know, their son is
gay let alone, you know,
they come from being Iraqi
and their son is gay,
which culturally
that's like, you know,
you get stoned for that.
I've been asked by
people usually
like how's it being an Iraqi
in the military, you know,
aren't you like fighting
your people?
Isn't that weird?
And, honestly, I don't think
I've ever let that question
like really simmer with me,
because I don't know
what I would have done,
you know what I mean, if I
really sat there and entertained
that question, because
on one hand, yes,
I am Iraqi culturally.
You know, I come from Iraq and
they're, you know, my people,
but I'm American as well, so.
It's a super strange and weird
gray area, because it's like,
but this is my country too.
I've been here since
I was 5 and, you know,
I value my freedom and
I will fight for it
and I enjoy my freedom.
[ Music ]
>> My name is Kardijetu
Dumbia [assumed spelling].
I go by the name Kadi
[assumed spelling].
I am from Mali.
I was born and raised
over there,
all the way to the age of 18.
I left my country when I was 18
years old, traveled to Europe
and fast forward, came
to the United States
about 24 years ago.
I live in Chicago right now.
I grew up in a very big
family, in a polygamist family.
I had four moms - four
moms in the family.
My father had four
wives and that's
where I was raised
[inaudible] for me
and from what I understand
like in my country, FGM,
which is female genital
mutilation, is not illegal
in my country [inaudible].
My hope is that of course
we have to have education
around this subject and we have
to have an open conversation
about this subject, because
nobody talks about FGM.
Nobody does.
If we can find a way
to educate the people
about not only the physical pain
- not only the physical pain,
because I don't remember
my physical pain.
The psychological
pain that stays
with you forever,
ever until you die.
[ Music ]
>> I'm going to reintroduce
the panelists back up.
We do have about ten minutes
for more of an interactive Q&A
in regards to the story
montage that we just listened to
and any other things
that, you know,
we may have overlooked
throughout the first segment.
So, yes?
>> I've - there's a focus here
on the immigrant community
and as an immigrant myself, I
don't want to diminish that,
but nonetheless, more than
a quarter of the Muslims
in America are the
children of converts,
overwhelmingly
African-Americans.
Have you included them in the
storytelling and if - if -
if so, would you and if not, why
didn't you have a representative
of that somewhere in the
montages or on the panel?
>> We have - you just
can't see somebody's image
when they're explaining
their story.
We have collected
and archived stories
from the black Muslim community,
from the African Muslim
community, various [inaudible],
as well first generation
to fourth generation.
It's very difficult in such a
short amount of time and also
with just audio to actually
show you the vast majority
of the collection and the
rich compilation of stories
that we have collected.
So, I do urge everybody
to go on the website.
It's malanational.org and
look through the stories
and hopefully you can also
see the diverse voices
that we have showcased
through the stories
that are spread throughout the
room with people's photographs
and just an excerpt
of their narrative.
So, I hope that answers
your question.
>> Hi. So, thank you
for your presentation.
This is - this is very
good and as a child
of enjoying StoryCorps
and the American Folklife,
this is - this is timely.
So, I was just curious
are - in your work,
are you capturing the diverse
ideological perspectives
within the Islamic
tradition as well?
I certainly appreciate your - my
colleague over there's comments.
I'm a fourth generation
African-American Muslim.
My grandparents - my great
grandparents converted
to Islam back in the 30s
through jazz musicians
and largely through [inaudible].
So - so, I appreciate that -
that comment as well, but -
but largely, I was just curious
in terms of just diversity
of perspectives,
liberal, secular,
chia [assumed spelling], --
>> Absolutely.
>> -- [inaudible], etc.
>> Liberal, secular, chia, suni
[assumed spelling], orthodox,
atheist, Muslims even.
We have spotlighted
stories from people
of all different backgrounds.
Our platform is open and that's
why we encourage you to go
on the site and I
wish there was a way
where we actually could
showcase all 350 plus stories.
In addition to not just
ideological or theological
or whatever it may
be that, you know,
there's so many different
divides
within the Muslim community
itself that our hope was
through storytelling
we're able to bring
and connect people
together from such a broad
and diverse community
that represents what
a Muslim American is.
And, I think just even
listening to these stories
and having these panelists
up here and listening
to just different
perspectives shows you
that we have actually
encompassed one
of the broadest range
collections of narratives
and stories and experiences and
we hope to continue to do more.
You know, our goal is to
have thousands of stories.
People from first generation
to fourth generation.
And, we've done recordings
with StoryCorps in partnership
with the Arab American
National Museum.
We've done it with the
Minneapolis community.
We do it in Chicago.
We do it in New York.
We've done it with the
university studies,
exchange students
from the MENA region.
So, like I said, it's - it's
- it's a very broad range
of just people's
individual experiences.
And, we never tell anybody
what to write or what to submit
or what to talk about.
They're free to do that.
It's your story.
You have autonomy over it and
you can share what you want.
>> I feel a bit odd since it's
kind of been raised twice now,
but I also had this reflection
that he raised that, you know,
others considerable,
you know, geographic
and ethnic diversities that's
really beautiful in chimes
through these stories.
It does seem like there's a
consistent story of immigration
or - or having parents in
the context of immigration.
And, so I was wondering
if you were doing any
outreach specifically
to communities that,
you know, whose -
whose story of immigration
forced or otherwise is
from several generations ago?
>> Those are - those
are amazing stories.
We've done - we've
had a few that are
like fourth generation
stories and even stories
that are not about immigration.
It's just about their
own personal experience.
Again, we would love to
reach out to a broader range
of people to, you know,
and different communities
within the Muslim American
communities to, you know,
come out and reach out to
us and share your story.
We're really, really, really
trying to keep pushing the power
of narratives, especially
diverse ones from people
of all different backgrounds.
So, we're very open to it.
Again, you know, reach out
to us through the website.
We're very active on social
media as well on Facebook,
Twitter, Instagram, and there's
several ways you can submit your
story or even sign up to
be recording your story
with StoryCorps in which
StoryCorps will actually talk
about that a little bit in -
in a little bit more
depth coming up.
So, there are very,
very different ways
where you can still get involved
and share your narrative
with MALA or your -
your story in general.
I hope that answered
the question.
>> Okay, again, I have a
question from Ahmed and Supna
in regard of particularly
when the hate crime again
was [inaudible] increased
because of - because
of involvement
of some distant individuals
into the terrorist attacks.
Where you feel that the Muslim
community placed themselves
and that is one question.
And, the second question is,
do you think that the Muslims
from Middle East and
Muslims from South Asia,
they're [inaudible] of
association with America
and with the American
dream has been different?
>> We have about a couple
of minutes to answer this
and there's a couple
more questions, so.
>> I'm not sure I understood
the question exactly,
but with regard to hate
crimes and their affect
on the Muslim American
community, I definitely feel
that there's a greater sense of
trepidation among communities
about what's going on and what
the appropriate response should
be, especially considering we're
three examples of individuals
and families that have tried to
I think in our own ways just to,
you know, work and
mind our own business
like everybody else
does, you know,
in their respective
communities across the nation.
I think it's - with respect
to the individuals perpetrating
the crime, I think that's
where your question was going.
I think that's where
communication is needed
and there is related
more to ignorance
than necessarily racism even
need to be responded to.
I - I think that, this is my
personal opinion, no MALA's,
but a hyper-partisan political
environment doesn't help.
We need to talk to
each other more.
We need to have projects
like MALA's narrative project be
expanded into more communities.
And, you know, for the questions
regarding to demographics
that haven't been
included yet, that -
that's a factor of funding.
[Inaudible] organization
which, you know,
I don't fund myself
or get a salary from.
They work really hard to try
to raise the money they can
to get people taped and it's
not [inaudible] aren't easy.
They're not making
anybody money.
So, nonprofits like [inaudible]
or any other community oriented
project needs public support.
And, it'll reach the
demographics you're seeing -
where you're seeing the gaps
if that support happens.
And, the second part of
your question was about --
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> -- salvation.
They do - they affiliate
themselves differently
from the American dream or
they have the same take --
>> I - I think it varies.
I think it varies.
I mean, I think when an audience
member, you know, raised concern
with that feeling of, you
know, victimization, I -
I think it's how the
issues are spoken about.
I personally feel more strongly
that every immigrant community
that has come into the
United States regardless
of era has faced its unique
challenges and Muslims are going
to face their challenges given
the political backdrop we find
ourselves in.
A hundred years from now,
I don't know what other
communities are going
to face integration issues,
but it's a part of growing.
Like, to me, what America
is, what America means,
that identity, it's life
and organic and it changes
and its influx and it's what you
contribute, what you take back
and it goes back to
communication and respect.
Even especially where
you see the differences.
That's where the communication
needs to happen ten times more.
And, we can't look at
each other caricatures,
which I think is the
issue on all sides
and that's my politics
and not Zainab's.
>> I - I mean I think
overall, yeah.
Some of these questions
are great because it goes
into a much larger
picture and there's
so many overlapping issues,
obviously, social issues
that kind of go into
this, but again our -
our goal is to scale our
project and showcase narratives,
showcase the diverse
individual experiences
and no two people's experiences
are ever going to be the same.
We did have a question here.
>> This is a much
narrower question.
A number of years ago I read
that the Mosque that has been
in continuous existence
in the United States the
longest is located in Iowa.
Do you know if that's true or do
you not know whether it's true
or not or do you know
definitely that it isn't true,
that there's some other Mosque
[laughter] which is the long -
has the longest exis -
continuous existence?
>> I'm not sure.
Does anybody else
have an answer?
Okay.
>> Anybody got Google?
>> No.
>> I do know that when
we were in Dearborn,
Michigan recording stories
with the Arab American
National Museum and StoryCorps,
that's actually one
of the oldest populations
of Muslim Americans.
Arab Americans - Arab Americans
also constu - like, they consist
of Christian Americans as well,
but that's actually one of the,
you know, primary
immigrant groups
that really was the
building block
of like a great American city.
Now, in regards to the
Mosque and the development
and the communities, I'm
sure it comes with time
as communities settle in.
So, I'm not sure
about the Iowa one,
but thank you for verifying.
[ Inaudible Response ]
Sure.
>> It's not just the Mosque -
it's not just the
Mosque in Iowa.
Muslims are part of
American folk culture,
though people don't
recognize it.
There's a play called
Oklahoma in which one
of the character is a peddler
named Ali Hakim and he's there
because there was so many
immigrant Muslim peddlers
in the midwest and he's, you
know, reflective of that.
Benjamin Franklin when he did
his census of Philadelphia,
he was - because
he was concerned
that he felt Pennsylvania
was being taken
over by Germans found
a Muslim community,
significant Muslim
population in Philadelphia.
That was in 1742, so.
>> Interesting.
>> I have a question for you.
Have you considered, I guess,
obviously it would be
a much larger project,
but hearing the voices
and hearing the stories
definitely brings it to life,
but hearing the panelists
and seeing them
and telling their stories
really puts it all together.
Would you I guess look at
making like a video form
of these stories with the
individuals narrating their
story as more like a documentary
or some larger format?
>> We have actually
discussed that quite a bit.
Again, a lot of it is,
you know, limited time,
limited budget, limit manpower.
MALA is all run by
volunteers and board members.
We're lucky to have, you
know, a good solid base
of like grassroots donors.
One of the things
that we did look
into is our StoryCorps segments
are so beautifully edited
and they're just so compelling
and it would be amazing
to have them animated even.
That was something that
we also had discussed.
So, there are quite a lot
of things in the pipeline
that we would like to do.
I think panels like this
really bring forth the voices.
So, MALA does do very
interactive events in Chicago
and in New York, obviously where
we have our largest network
of volunteers and, you know,
people who are really committed
to making the event happen.
And, we would love to continue
doing a lot more nationwide
programs and events.
The moral to this, we are
having something similar to this
in Chicago with the Chicago
Cultural Alliance in October.
And, you know, hopefully we can
continue scaling this project.
So, that's why we're very
grateful for everybody
that is here and for StoryCorps
for giving us the opportunity
to bring these stories
more mainstream,
as well as the American Folklife
Center for making, you know,
putting this kind of an
event on the map in regards
to the significance of such
stories and also The Library
of Congress where the stories
are actually archived and housed
for generations to come.
I hope that answers
your question.
[ Inaudible Response ]
My next presenter
and first of all,
I want to thank the panelists
for their incredible, you know,
input, feedback and also
to share your story
on a - on a stage.
It's not easy.
So, please let's have a warm
round of applause for them.
[ Applause ]
Our next speaker is
Tamara [assumed spelling]
and she is from StoryCorps.
And, these are all StoryCorps
segments that you were able
to listen to today
that were recorded
through a community partnership
with MALA and StoryCorps
and they've done incredible
work in archiving stories,
hundreds of thousands of
stories from Americans
from all walks of life.
I'm very, very honored
to introduce Tamara
and StoryCorps tonight.
[ Applause ]
>> Hello. Hello.
I'm very pleased
to be here today.
Again, my name is
Tamara Thompson
and I'm the Archive
Manager at StoryCorps.
Okay. Are we okay with the -
everyone can hear me all right?
Okay. Excuse me.
Yes, again, I'm - I'm
very pleased to be here
to talk a little bit more
about the partnership
that StoryCorps has with MALA
and also the contributions
MALA has made
to the StoryCorps archive.
Now, before we get
started with that,
I'd like to talk a little bit
about StoryCorps for those
of you who are unfamiliar
with us.
So, StoryCorps is
an independent,
nonprofit organization
that was founded in 2003
by radio documentarian
Dave Isay.
Now, our mission is
relatively simple.
It is to record, preserve
and share humanity stories
and in pursuit of this mission,
we hope to really build a sense
of compassion and empathy
throughout humanity as well.
So, this is how it works.
We have recording locations
in San Francisco,
Atlanta, and Chicago.
We also have a mobile
booth that travels
around different cities each
month recording stories.
And, we have what's called
a national team in New York
which is based out of New
York, but they travel all
over the country
recording stories as well.
And so, you might come into one
of our booths with a friend,
a family member, someone
you know or someone you'd
like to get to know
a little bit more
and you have a 40-minute
conversation with that person.
It would be recorded by one
of our trained facilitators
who would be taking notes during
the process and afterwords,
of course, you would receive
a copy of the interview.
And, with the participants
permission, we would also add
that interview to the
StoryCorps archive.
Now, every interview
that is part
of the StoryCorps archive is
actually housed right here
at The Library of Congress, at
the American Folklife Center.
So, those of you who are
interested in hearing some
of these stories from the MALA
collection and other collections
that we have in the
StoryCorps archive.
You can make a reservation at
the American Folklife Center
and go and listen to
some of the stories.
We are hoping to put a large
portion of the archive online
in the next year or so.
So, stay tuned for
more details on that.
So, at this point,
we've collected
over 70 thousand interviews.
Now, you cannot collect 70
thousand interviews in a silo.
We rely on partnerships like
MALA to reach participants,
to create the archive
that we have today.
And, we would be unable
to pursue our mission
without the partners that
we work with like MALA.
There would be very little
recording, preserving or sharing
if we didn't have
any interviews.
So, we see the stories in
our archive as contributions
from participants and
organizations as well.
So, I do want to make sure
that everyone knows how
grateful StoryCorps is
to be working with MALA.
And, very, very grateful to be -
to have been connected
with - with MALA.
This happened back in 2014.
So, in 2014, our
Chicago story booth lead
by Shirley Alfaro was very
interested in making sure
that we reached out
to Muslim communities.
And, so they were attempting to
find partnerships with these -
within these communities
and they were having
some difficulty.
So, they mentioned this
to another partner
organization of ours.
We have a partnership
with the radio -
we have a radio station
partnership with WBEZ.
And, a person from
WBEZ connected Shirley
and her Chicago team
to Zainab and MALA.
And, thus the partnership
was forged.
In 2015, actually December
- December the 6th 20 -
2015 was the very first
interview recorded
in partnership between
StoryCorps and MALA.
And, sense then, there have
been 88 interviews recorded
with over 90 participants
and more to be recorded.
And, so this has been one of
the most successful partnerships
to come out of the
Chicago booth.
And, it's been a
really incredible ride.
And, so I - I again, thank the
Chicago booth and the folks
at MALA for starting
this partnership.
Now, for those of you who've not
really perused the collection,
if you haven't had an
opportunity to do so,
I'd like to give a brief
snapshot of the types of stories
that are there and the
individuals who are part
of this archive, part of
this journey's collection.
Now, some of the themes that
you'll hear are about home,
acceptance, identity, culture,
music, art, resilience.
Some of these are
traumatic stories.
Some of these stories are about
painful events, but they're also
about love and laughter
and hope.
The people who are presenting
their stories are artists,
visionaries, thinkers, writers,
creators, content producers,
educators, activists,
friends and family members,
colleagues, mentors and mentees.
There are so many
different types of stories
that are being told and so
many types of participants
who are part of this project.
In addition, there are dozens
of countries represented.
Zainab read a few early on and
so I'll just list a couple.
But, there's Tunisia, Libya,
Saudi Arabia, India, London,
Nigeria, Egypt, Lebanon,
and the list goes on.
It's a really fantastic project
that we are very
grateful to be a part of.
And, again, emphasizing how
important partnerships are
in order to get the word
out about StoryCorps,
to have people understand that
their stories are important
and whether you record
your story with StoryCorps
or another organization or
on your own, it's important
to capture these stories.
It's important to make sure your
voice is heard and the stories
of your community, whatever
type of community that may be,
are archived and
saved in perpetuity.
So, with that I would just
like to again encourage you all
to find out more
information about StoryCorps
and our many partnerships
by visiting our website.
If you're interested in starting
a partnership with StoryCorps,
there is information
available on our website.
If you're interested in
hearing more about MALA,
they have a fantastic website.
So, you should definitely
check that out.
Again, you can also make a
reservation here at The Library
of Congress, at the American
Folklife Center and listen
to interviews here in The
Library of Congress, the beauty
and splendor of The
Library of Congress.
And, again, remember
to share your stories,
record your stories.
And, coming up next, we're going
to have Julia Kim who is one
of the individuals responsible
for processing the
StoryCorps archive
and ingesting the materials
that we send to her.
So, she's got some
very interesting things
to talk about.
One of which is another way
that you can record your stories
by using the StoryCorps app.
So, thank you very
much and take care.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi. I'm Julia Kim.
I have the privilege of actually
working with these interviews
and stories when they
come here to the library.
I'm just going to
spend ten minutes sort
of getting more granular
and talking
about the app that's available
on smartphones to use.
So, if you are interested in
contributing to the - StoryCorps
and to the archive, you can go
home and do that right away.
But, I'm going to spend most
of my time specifically
talking about keywords.
And, I think this actually loops
back to a lot of the themes
that we've been actually
talking about earlier today.
Securers have a very
maybe obvious function,
in that they make it
easier for us to get a sense
in what are these discrete
files that have sort of -
they can gibberish names.
So, you can see at the top
there's a lot of keywords,
maybe not all of you can see
those, but, you know, 100 years,
Clayton, family,
Libbey High School.
So, there are dates, locations,
there are even like full names.
And, then on the bottom
and this just happened
to be on the screen.
It's a great convo.
Great convo might be
an app descriptor,
but it doesn't help us a lot
of the times down the line.
When we're trying to understand
what is the value of this story?
What is going on here?
What are the themes that
we're talking about?
So, on a very practical level
as - as we've been talking
about today, you
can come on over
and take a look at
these stories.
And, this collection is
obviously extremely pop -
popular for patrons, students,
researchers who are interested
in this huge [inaudible] of
interviews that, you know,
obviously go across a broad
section of not just America,
but all around the world.
So, we often get questions like
I want to listen to interviews
about disabilities or I'm
interested in native in -
indigenous oral histories.
So, this loops back to keywords.
Great convo isn't going to help,
but if you have disabilities,
for example, in the first one as
a key word, we can pull that up
for you for your family members,
for whoever is interested
really.
And, really the more
keywords you have the more
that we can search.
So, if someone comes in and
asks for a topic, for example,
indigenous in that last one,
we might - we might pull
up everything related to
indigenous, but we'd have
to think what are other
labels and words around that.
So, native, first
nation, native American.
So, this gets back to
categories and labels.
This is just the way that we
have to work in terms of trying
to figure out what are
these stories about?
Who are the people talking?
And, what is the value?
So, people obviously
categorize things differently,
so this is where you
and your role as sort
of like the first archivist
doing the interviews comment
in terms of interpreting
what - what your role is -
or what your identity is maybe
or what are the themes here.
What is the value here?
Right. Ultimately,
what is the value
in this story and interview?
And, that's really the
main point of this talk.
It's that you can go
home and you can decide.
Is it appropriate
to do first nation
or is it appropriate
to do indigenous?
Is it appropriate to do Muslim?
Is it appropriate to
do Muslim American?
But, what I'm talking about
very broadly is then trying
to address all these
questions, like who, what,
where and then in
these keywords.
So, if you actually
look in the app,
it'll give you some examples
of how to answer these things.
So, they can be - we would
like ideally for them
to be both very broad.
For example, family, mother,
sister in terms of relationships
that are being talked
about, but also full names.
So, if - if you come in and
say my mother, [inaudible] Kim,
wants to hear her
interview, I can search that.
It has to actually be put in.
So, there's a - there's sort
of a bounce that we're trying
to hit in terms of
broader themes,
but also very - a
lot of specificity.
And, here's a great
example actually
from the StoryCorps.me
website which has a lot
of great resources that sort of
walk you through what our best
and ideal practice is.
So, you don't - you're not
completely limited to keywords,
but also the interview title
can be very descriptive.
So, here it's Flatbush Community
Garden Center, Jane and John
on the transformative
power of urban gardening,
and then summary
and descriptions.
So, in this example,
I found the summary
and description really
important because it talks
about the relationship
actually between the interview
and interviewee, as they
are both the co-founders
of this garden that's
being talked about.
This is actually a
look at the public API
for the StoryCorps.me.
So, once you submit your - press
the submit button on the phone,
it's actually immediately
available on the API publically,
which I find really amazing.
So, you can find, for example,
in this - this is an example
from the last couple of days
from the great Ramadan listen,
which is another big
initiative by StoryCorps.me.
And, so you can see
that there are -
there are very specific
keywords,
but in this one really,
they are just really Muslim
and Islam related keywords
and they're actually the
only keywords really,
so they're very sparse
in that way.
So, you can see another example
here of how these keywords look
on the public API if
you were to submit them.
So, Ramadan and then the
locations, Oregon, United States
and dates and so forth.
I thought it would be really
interesting because of the -
the discussion about diversity
and cross sections to look
at some MALA StoryCorps
keywords that were put in.
So, I found it really
interesting that in -
in a broad number
of them actually,
it seemed like maybe Islam and
Muslim were not explicitly put
in and yet, maybe there
are themes around it
or maybe it was part -
it was part of this
collection in some way.
And, so I think it - it
comes back to - over here,
here's another really good one
where the different keywords
included for example advice,
aging, art, college,
divorce, ethnic identity,
cultural expectations,
independence,
leadership, volunteerism.
And, these were definitely
very broad applicable themes
on this interview.
But, maybe if I had
been looking for this
and it hadn't been
labeled as part of MALA,
I would not have
found this collection.
So, if somebody came in and said
I want, you know, this interview
about Muslims - this interview,
for example, would have not -
would have not come
up in the search,
but I also think maybe it wasn't
- maybe it wasn't relevant.
Going back to some of the
excerpts that we heard earlier,
maybe this person didn't feel
comfortable self-identity
strictly as Muslim or maybe
this person was atheist, but,
you know, had some sort
of cultural relationship
or - of some kind.
So, I think it's -
it's interesting to -
to think about how these
labels are very important
and they have a very, very
practical usage, so we have -
we have people coming
in all the time asking
about the StoryCorps interviews,
but also that there's a
high level of interpretation
when you go home and use
your phone and use the app
and that you can
self-identify if you want to.
You can explicitly say I'm going
to identify as Korean American
or I choose not to because
I feel like there's a sort
of flattening affect
with the keywords
or I just don't feel
comfortable with that.
So, that's sort of
my ten minutes.
But, I know you must think, wow,
this is chaotic, how do manage
and classify when you
have 80,000 interviews.
I'm just going to point out that
there's - there's a whole system
in place where we - at
the library and archivists
and librarians here
do this professionally
and their categories and ways to
do this, so this is a snapshot
of our authority list,
specifically around Muslim.
So, there're - there are
whole areas of study here,
but the point of the
app and in some ways one
of the great things
about the app is
that it embraces your own
interpretation and that if -
when - as you - when you -
when you go home and contribute
to this, you can do
whatever you want in terms
of identifying yourself or not.
So, I would encourage you
to use the app and come
and use your collections and
sort of keywords in ten minutes.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Hello.
>> Thank you to Julia
and thank you
to everyone who's spoken today.
It's been an amazing couple
of hours of stories and -
and talking about
stories and talking
about what they mean to us.
So, we want to thank
everyone from MALA who's here
and everyone from StoryCorps.
And, my name is Steve
Winick and I work
for the American
Folklife Center,
so I'm from that third
organization you have been
hearing about quite a bit.
And, I'm here to talk
to you about a sort
of more general approach
to collecting cultural
documentation.
So, I think to begin we can say
that the genius of StoryCorps is
that the - the StoryCorps
principal was
to facilitate these
kinds of interviews.
Right. Make them really
easy for people to do.
And, in so doing, they -
they sort of made a lot
of those background decisions
that you have to make
if you're going to do
cultural documentation,
they made those decisions
for you and put them in place
so that you could just
go in and do interviews.
And, the result of this is
is this amazing collection
of recorded interviews and
- and what comes out of
that are these wonderful
edited stories that you hear
on the radio or that you can
see in animations on YouTube.
They've done some really great
things with them as well.
The - the only thing about
this approach that can be seen
as a drawback is the, you
know, we've got a question,
for example, are you going
to make a film documentary.
And, you can't do that
with a documentation
that StoryCorps has
produced exclusively.
You would have to go in and make
other documentation including
footage in order to do that.
And so, taking a step backwards
is what I'm going to do now
and talk about doing
documentation, but you have
to decide what the model is
before you start that process.
And, I'm going to be talking
sort of jumping off from a book
that the American Folklife
Center has just put
out about a year ago.
It's called Folklife
and Field Work.
And, there are copies of this
book on the table outside.
Everyone could have
taken one on the way in,
but you can now take
one on the way
out if you didn't take
one on the way in.
And, this describes that process
of doing cultural documentation
from the sort of
beginning to the end,
the soup to nuts approach.
So, I'm going to start.
So, this is really
about thinking
about folklife field work
in - in a digital world.
So, it begins with this
question of what is folklife
and here's where I'm nervous.
You won't be able to read the
slide, but it won't matter,
because I'll - I'll
read it for you as well.
So, one of the great
things about being
at the American Folklife
Center, our - our director
at the beginning,
Betsy Peterson,
explained that we were placed
here at The Library of Congress
in order to document the
diversity of American folklife
and that really is our
legislation and it's -
it's an inspiring piece of
legislation because it begins
by saying how important
diversity is to American life
and that we should be
documenting it and -
and keeping - preserving
that documentation
in The Library of Congress.
And, so that's - that's a
great part of the legislation,
but another part is that it
actually defines folklife
so that it can direct
us as to what it is
that we're supposed to document.
And so, this actually
- this definition
of folklife actually
comes from the public law
that established the
American Folklife Center,
so this is the wisdom
of the U.S. Congress.
And, I'm not just saying
that because I have to.
So, this is how they
define folklife.
The traditional expressive
shared culture of various groups
in the United States,
familial, ethnic, occupational,
religious and regional.
It says expressive culture
includes a wide range
of creative and symbolic
forms such as custom, belief,
technical skill, language,
literature, art, architecture,
music, play, dance,
drama, ritual, pageantry
and handy craft and
that it explains
that these expressions
are mainly learned orally
by imitation or in performance
and are generally maintained
or perpetuated without
benefit or formal instruction
or institutional direction.
So, essentially, it's saying
that - that folklife is -
is sort of small scaled,
traditional culture
that is maintained in
communities of all kinds.
And, the American Folklife
Center exists to document
and preserve such culture.
So, now the question is
what is this word fieldwork,
which is in the title, and I
put ethnographic in parentheses
because other disciplines
use fieldwork too,
like geologists consider
going out and collecting rocks
to be a form of fieldwork
and that's not what
we're talking about.
We're talking about
cultural documentation.
So, what fieldwork really is
is the firsthand observation
and documentation of
culture and this results
in various forms
of documentation.
And, you see a list of the kinds
of things that you might end
up with if you did
ethnographic field work.
And, many of these forms now are
going to be - come in the form
of digital files, right.
Even though they're written
notes, they're actually going
to be Word documents as opposed
to a notebook in a lot of cases.
So, you end up with a lot of
digital files and you also end
up probably with some analog
materials, drawings, objects,
and I put forms in there,
because it's important
to get people's permission,
which we'll talk
about in a minute.
And, so we - forms come
with pretty much any
collection of this type.
And so, here's how you would
get started in such a process.
The first thing that
you have to do is think
about what your goals
and outcomes are, right.
So, one kind of -
of documentation
or of field work is just
to understand the
community for yourself.
So, you're a scholar, right,
and you want to know more
about this community,
so you go in to -
to make that understanding
for yourself.
But, another kind is when
you're helping the community
in some way, that is they need
to get a grant for example
and they need documentation
of certain of the things
that they do in order
to get that grant.
So, that's another
possible model of -
of folklife field work.
It's for helping the community
and the two, of course,
are not only not
mutually exclusive,
but they work together
very well.
So, sometimes you start out
just learning about the culture,
but then people within
the culture realize
that there's some way
that you can help them
with this documentation.
That happens to folklores all
the time and we role with that.
We try to help the
communities as much as we can.
And, finally, a third thing that
you need to think about in terms
of goals and outcomes is
specific end products.
Are you, for example,
thinking about writing a book
or are you going to
make a documentary as -
as someone mentioned
in the room.
All of these things - all
of these three decisions -
are you understanding
the community,
how are you helping
and what specific end
product do you want
to create will affect the
kinds of docu - documentation
that you produce, right.
So, if you - if you know
that you want to make a film,
then you have to start thinking
about that kind of documentation
about making video
footage, for example.
And, then you decide
what to document.
And, I love the fact that
both Julia and I have the who,
what, where slide, right.
But, this is very important
because if you start
with something that's too broad,
you will never finish
your project
or even get your
project started.
So, you - so really those three
are the three main questions
that you usually ask.
Who meaning which community
are you documenting?
What meaning what facet of this
huge thing called folklife do
you want to study?
And, thirdly, where
are you going to do it?
So, I mean, just as an
example, if you wanted
to study traditional
Pakistani weddings, right.
You could - you could say
well, I'll study them all
over the world, but that would
not be a realistic project.
So, you want to have, you know,
each one of these items, you -
you want to have an idea for -
for what the value of that is.
So, I'm going to do it in
New York City, for example,
and that will make that project
a lot easier to complete.
And, then you want to think
in advance about archiving,
sustainability and
access, right.
So, you are going
to create files,
these - these digital files.
In 20 years, is anyone
going to - going to be able
to use the files
that you've created?
That's a problem for all
of us and it's a problem
that is best solved by
consulting with professionals,
because it, you know, these
things change all the time
and folks within archives
and libraries are the people
who really know the
answers to these questions
or at least know, you know,
the trajectories that we're on
and can give you the best
answers that we know today.
And so, really what
this is saying is
if you want your collection
to be accessible in the future
and you want the files
to be sustainable
so that even you can use them
in the future, you probably want
to talk to someone at some point
in your process and early -
the earlier the better, right.
So, if you talk to an
archivist before you even start,
that's probably better than
creating the documentation
and then talking to them later.
And, what this means is when
you're going to do a project,
you sort of think about
in advance what kind
of archive do I think this
might belong in, find that kind
of archive and talk
to someone there.
And, even if they aren't
sure they're interested
in the collection
until they see it,
which is quite often the case,
they'd be willing often to talk
to you about what
standards they would accept
and why they would
accept those standards
and what your next best
option is and all kinds
of questions like that.
So, we really encourage
you to talk to an archive
in advance of doing a project.
There are ethics
considerations involved
in any field work project.
Mainly, the main
issue is to be honest
and transparent about
everything.
So, never deceive people.
Never collect information
on false pretenses.
If you don't know what
you're going to do
with the documentation, it's -
that's okay, but if you do know,
if you know you're making a
film, then you should tell them
that that's what you're doing.
There's - there's really
not a good reason usually
to conceal what you're
doing from the people
that you're interviewing.
And, the second part
of this is to make sure
that you get permission,
express permission,
to use people's materials, that
is their image, their voice.
And, usually we do this through
the use of release forms,
which I'll talk about a little
bit in a - in a few minutes.
After you've done all that,
right, after you know what kind
of project you're doing,
where you're doing it,
what kind of archive you might
want to turn this material into,
what kind of standards
that archive would need,
all of those questions,
then you can decide
on the equipment needs
for recording this
particular project.
After you do that, you do
some preliminary research,
that is to say you're studying
Pakistani weddings in New York,
well you go online and see what
you can find out about that.
You go to the library and you
see if there are books about it,
articles about it that can help
you in your - in your planning
of the initial kinds
of fieldwork.
And, then you start making
community connections.
Now, in many cases, people
who are starting this kind
of project are starting it
because they already have
community connections.
They know someone in
the community, they -
they've been interested
in it for a long time,
but if you don't, you
look for cultural centers.
You look for civic
organizations.
Those kinds of places that
are used to being brokers
between the culture and other
people who are from outside.
And, you go and talk to them
and see whom might be interested
in talking to you, what
use this project might have
within the community and
how you can help and fit
into the community's needs.
And, after you do that,
you can then decide
on the real specifics of
what you want to document.
So, you know, I've got
to now come up with a way
to document the dress,
the music, and the food
that are going to be part
of three Pakistani
weddings in New York.
This is just a project that
I made up for the purposes
of this talk, but that's an
example of the kinds of things
that you - that you then come
up with when you narrow it
down to - to this
level of the specifics.
And, you then start
thinking about this process
that in anthropology or folklore
we call participant observation.
Okay. So, how is it that you are
going to be part of these events
and not be in the way and
there are two ways to do that,
usually that - that - that
ethnographers use a lot.
One is to become a
learner of some kind.
So, if you're interested in a
musical tradition, for example,
you apprentice yourself
to a player and you learn
to play the instrument
and you document it
through that process
of learning.
And, the other is to become
a helper of some kind.
So, if you're - if you're
not going to be the chef
at the wedding, you can
still help sweep the floor
and do other unglamorous
but very useful tasks
that will put you in the place
that you want to be in order
to document it and make
you useful to the community
so that they're happier
there and they're happy
that you're documenting
their event as well.
And, then once you've - you've
got yourself, you know, you -
you - you got yourself
placed, that's when you figure
out who the people are that
you're going to interview
and you're going to setup
your first interviews.
And, then, of course, before
you actually go in the field,
you have to learn to use that
equipment that you selected
through that other process,
which just means you have a
little practice, you know,
have some practice sessions
and go through that.
And, I mentioned release forms.
You want to design release forms
or obtain them from somewhere.
This book has release
forms in it,
so that's a very helpful
thing that you can just pull
out the versions
that are in here.
And, those release forms are
again to give you permission
to use what you collect.
So, if I have done an interview
with someone on video and I want
to put it in a film, it's
helpful from the beginning
to have had that
person's consent,
because otherwise you
might go back to them later
and they say well, you know,
I was happy to talk to you,
but I don't want it in the
film and then, you know, that -
that amount of footage is
not as - as helpful to you
as it would have been.
So, it's always good to
know these things in advance
and this is why you have your
release forms at the outset.
And, then you can go ahead
and schedule your interviews.
You create your questions,
so you, you know,
you figure out what it is you
want to ask and how you're going
to get the information that
you need and you go ahead
and you conduct your
first interview.
So, now my point in going
through all those steps was
to show you that
with StoryCorps,
the wonderful thing is
you walk into the booth
and you conduct your
first interview.
You don't have to go
through those - those steps.
But, if you're doing a different
kind of documentary project,
you do and it's a really
good idea to have all
of this stuff thought
out in advance
and this is what the process
of folklife fieldwork
often is like.
So, that's just the beginning.
So, then you've just gotten
your first interview and then,
of course, from there, you
just take it from there, right.
Those people will introduce
you to other people,
you know what the events
are, you've thought
about what the events are
that you have to document
and how you have to do that, so
you then you have a plan for -
for the process of this project.
So, as you see, there are a lot
of steps involved in planning it
that - that you don't have to do
at StoryCorps, but if you're -
if you're starting from
scratch, you might have
to do all of these things.
One thing to keep in mind,
I know that this can sound
daunting, and so the last thing
to keep in mind is have
fun on your project.
Don't let it get - don't
let it bog you down.
And, a lot of the
time, you know,
you'll find that you get
interested in doing a project
like this because you
already have relationships
in the community and sometimes
the community has already
started the process of
documentation and you are sort
of contributing to something
that's already ongoing.
And, if that's the case,
although you can't
make this plan
from the very beginning
the way I just outlined,
you can take a look at
what's already there,
see how well it fits
into these parameters
and do anything retro -
retroactively that you can
to get this ready
for archiving later.
And, if you - there
are other tips.
I can't go through the
whole book, but you can,
because the book is free and
it's right outside on the table.
So, there are other tips
for doing a whole
ethnographic project
and for making those materials
that you create sustainable
and accessible in the future in
an archive and we really hope
that you'll do that and you'll
think about all the great ways
that you can go out there
and - and document culture.
So, once again I want to
thank all our friends at MALA
and StoryCorps and on behalf of
the American Folklife Center,
just say thank you for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.